Right?
There's,
there's something to the placebo effect,
right?
So if there,
if,
if that is a real thing,
if you can convince your body that it's got the medicine that it needs and it
starts to heal,
even though there's no medicine,
there's gotta be something that is working against you as well with the wrong
mindset.
Right?
It's funny to me to hear people rediscovering the placebo effect.
Now,
I wrote a book in 1983 called health and healing and had two chapters in there
on placebos.
And what I wrote is that the,
the greatest problem is that we,
in the,
when we talk about placebos,
it's in phrases like,
how do you know that's not just a placebo effect?
The most interesting word there was just right,
or we have to rule out the placebo effect,
right?
We should be rolling it in,
man.
That's the meat of medicine.
That's pure healing from within mediated by belief on mixed up with the direct
effects of treatment.
That's what you want to make happen more at the time.
It just is a mind fuck for a lot of people.
Cause they're like,
how am I tricking myself into getting better?
Why can't I just do it?
Because that had must have something to do with the structure of the brain that
the part of the brain in which our will is,
isn't,
it doesn't connect directly to the machinery of the body to be autonomic nervous
system.
So you have to find some way of getting around that.
One way is to project belief on to something external and then let it work for
you.
Yeah,
but that's so strange that the mind works that way.
It would seem like,
wouldn't it be an evolutionary advantage?
Just have it at access,
you know,
like sure.
That'd be nice.
But that's the same thing.
You know that's a similar problem to why can't you just get high without taking
a drug?
The high is in your brain,
not in the drug.
The drug is a trigger that releases it.
Why can't we just sit down and say,
well I'm going to be high for the next 10 minutes.
So the same thing.
We don't have access to those controls to.
It just seems like that one though.
Healing and getting better.
That one seems like it's something that we should as a culture concentrate on.
Yeah,
for sure.
We really concentrate on is actual medicine.
One way to concentrate on that is by giving people greater confidence in their
body's ability to do that.
And doctors have great power to do that because patients project a lot of belief
on them.
I've had many patients over the years who said that the most important thing I
did for them was that I was the only doctor who told them they could get better.
I mean,
astonishing.
Mm.
Yeah.
Is it because doctors are just seen too many patients and they're overwhelmed
and they got a legal bills and they have,
I think some,
I,
I've thought about this a lot and I,
there's also the negative side of this.
I've seen what there's something called medical hexing in which doctors say
things that actually interfere with healing or cause people to get worse.
And I think a lot of this is done unconsciously.
Uh,
so here's one of my thoughts in their training.
Um,
doctors see a very skewed sample of sick people.
They see very sick people in hospitals and in that group,
healing is less likely to happen.
But if you look at the total spectrum of illness,
the vast majority of things get better on their own.
So I think,
you know,
observing in yourself,
ha wound healing is a good one to start with,
to get greater confidence in your body's to do things that's really valuable.
So,
but this obviously you're not talking about catastrophic injuries,
you just talking about general wellness.
I think even in the case of of catastrophic injury,
this stuff operates.
I worked a lot with hypnotherapists over the years and one of the,
one of my colleagues did a lot of work in training paramedics to be really
careful about what you say around unconscious people who have been massively
injured.
Uh,
you know,
when the,
if a,
if a paramedic takes an automobile accident victim and they're putting them in
and says this one's a corner,
that is a bad thing,
you know,
the unconscious mind on.
And on the other hand you'll say something opposite to a person.
You can see cases where you can stop bleeding in unconscious people,
severely injured just by giving them suggestions.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So when you're saying someone's a goner,
you trigger stress.
Are you trigger helplessness?
What does have a medically trained person tell you that you're not going to
live?
That's a curse.
Yeah,
medical hex.
How strange is it that sometimes your life is hanging on the border of you
believing you're going to be okay and you believe in you're not going to be
okay.
So you want to be very careful about,
you know,
whose hands you place yourself in.
Yes.
It never want to stay in treatment with a doctor who thinks she can't get
better.
Uh,
negative doc.
Well doctors are just like every other occupation.
If people that are really good at it and a really concentrated and focus and
it's people that are half fascinating.
Well the ones I trained through our University of Arizona Center for Integrative
Medicine get it.
You know,
we're putting out,
we've graduated about 1600 physicians now from very intensive training there in
practice all over the country.
Teaching other people is a good thing.
Now when you say integrative medicine,
when they're in practice,
are they essentially general practitioners?
We've trained people from all specialties.
Any specialty you can name,
we've trained them.
So orthopedic surgeons and neurologists,
dermatologists,
anything ever does.
Yeah.
And so you try to tend to look at them.
We teach them all the things they didn't get in medical school,
nutrition,
mindbody interactions,
uh,
strengths and weaknesses of alternative medicine,
herbal medicine,
all that.
Like say someone comes to you and maybe they have a bad case of psoriasis,
autoimmune issue with that prime,
prime target for mind,
body medicine for traditional Chinese medicine,
which often works well and in that dietary changed,
but people on an anti inflammatory diet,
use of natural products that reduce inflammation.
So there's a wide range of things to choose from.
And this does not reject the conventional treatment.
You know,
we may use conventional medication,
but if you do,
I recommend using the lowest dose,
the least potent agent.
Start off with that and you can ramp up if you need to.